the way I heard that you took your son's
class on a field trip I'm about to do a
field trip with my dog I did my son's
class was obsessed with Greek myths and
uh the whole second grade class Greek
myths and Greek Heroes and so I took
them to go see Hades town on Broadway
yeah there we are yeah
and it was it was me and uh 26 second
graders and their parents oh
um which was fun we really it was it was
a loud matinee for the cast of hadestown
um so was your family involved with your
school projects when you were a kid do
you get involved with your kids
um yes I did we my son and I actually
made a video for my wife's 40th birthday
and he he wrote the whole thing and I
edited it with my friend Alex Horowitz
but yeah but my parents totally like I
did a I remember doing a video
uh book report of the push cart war in
third grade and my grandmother's in it
my great-grandmother's in it they all
played teachers and my mom was in it and
I made them act out scenes from the book
and filmed it with like a huge camcorder
I love Force family fun yeah
we actually have this video
you're convenient we have five people to
play the
role of teachers on strike
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
your mother I see where you get your
passion my mom was so committed though
you can tell I'm genuinely scared in
that video I knew what was happening I
told her what to say to me but then she
gave it such ferocity I see where you
get it from yeah I'm like against the
wall with my little mayor's hat I love
it she was full on yelling at you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]